bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on est avec
stéphane qu'il ya une solution ou rendre
vos enfants pour faire de nos enfants
des super héros
[Musique]
est ce que tu peux m'expliquer comment
ça se passe comment ça marche pour nous
montrer parce que c'est super
intéressante c'est une autre
connectables pour les enfants ont cuit
vais le principe c'est que l'on créé
leur propre super héros choisir son nom
son costume ses super pouvoirs et se
servir de ce super héros dans la plaine
de jeux notamment connectant deux mois
l'ensemble pas raconter son super héros
consolide son petit camarade mais pour
perd tous ses jeux ses activités de
heroes a besoin d'énergie dont prélat
sourire l'énergie de la terre ferme de
la halle
parsemer on va inciter les enfants à
faire du sport
d'où son épouse excéderait et réussi des
alertes pour les allergies des rappels
pour la maison decca mans
et des solutions pour les parents comme
ça veut dire que plus l'enfant la banane
et la patate
puis va devenir un super héros aura plus
à faire évoluer son super héros 300
autres exactement plus va faire détester
zigbee puis leur adoption et d'activités
de jeux ludiques et plus fait depuis la
toile et la coiffure sont les rhodiens
la corse alors du coup l'ironie
ressemble à quoi il ressemble à un degré
ils sont complètement
crème l'ex-responsable par l'enfant
pourra créer son fessier on va choisir
une des huit couleurs on va choisir si
c'est un garçon
il donnait à nous et on va presque alors
du coup tu disais donc les
fonctionnalités si on rentre dedans ou
la géolocalisation pour les parents pour
savoir où sont leurs enfants alors c'est
sympa retape gallas déjà la grippe chez
les enfants de 5 à 12 ans c'est grosso
modo des moments où je commence à savoir
lire jusqu'au moment là je vais avoir
mon propre smartphone on est à faire cet
entre deux
ah d'accord super donc ça veut dire que
l'enfant pour lui puisqu'il voit ses
côtés mellick
mais pour les parents il ya un coût très
coté de sécurité de surveiller l'enfant
savoir ce qui c'est une dizaine par
rapport aux allergies vraiment ça se
passe alors une petite caméra tout
permet la lecture des codes barres et
aux parents
l'or enregistrait les allergènes 2
auquel est sensible
on va donner un retour immédiat sur la
main
s'il a le droit ou pas de manger le
producteur ça veut dire que vous avez un
partenariat avec les grands industriels
de taille
non on a le risque comme ça avec les
codes-barres les produits qui sont en
rapport avec les copains et tous les
allergènes qui sont
[Musique]
alors donc il ya sage qu'est ce qu'on
retrouve encore comme fonctionnalité via
à peine sur la prise de médicaments
quand l'entente et à l'école et qu'il a
besoin de médicaments la banque il fait
un rappel et le récompenser qu'ont ils
fait bien sûr répond et l'idée vraiment
c'est franchement greg termes de santé
derrière plus jeux ludiques mais et
dédié aux enfants par la suite alors été
adressés des sujets comme l'internet
l'autisme
des pathologies plus super super alors
du coup c'est pourquoi est-ce qu'on peut
la trouver
on va faire de financement
en janvier
suite à quoi on va faire une demande
des gogos de février hamas je vous
invite à
même sur film et 3 pb pour vous inscrire
sur la liste des évolutions depuis les
jeunes et le ghana la description pour
aller voir les premiers produits seront
distribués début de l'été
pour être dans les rayons à la rentrée
et le canoë et a lancé que si c'était
elle vient d'où l'idée de faire ce
produit alors l'idée est bien de moi de
mon expérience personnelle
j'étais ce qu'on appelle un gros bébé
quand j'étais
drogue la classe et à l'âge adulte en
fait sont tombés dans l'obésité morbide
donc
en 2003 j'ai perdu à peu près 80 kg
le
en fait il ya quelques années je me suis
demandé qu'est ce que ma mère aurait pu
faire un stage là pour me motiver pour
m'insulter je me suis rendue compte
qu'elle n'avait pas
faire la courbe du coût de la vie qu'est
ce qui à cet âge là qui m'a sauvée à
faire attention à ma santé et on s'est
dit que la meilleure des choses à faire
c'est laisser jouer les enfants est
juste de les accompagner noms des
coureurs comme quoi les histoires
personnelles sans même toujours sur des
projets qui sont ancrées engenio bon
écoute merci beaucoup à toi je vous
invite vous aimez céder les petits
commentaires si vous êtes parents si
vous êtes même des enfants parce qu'on a
des gens qui sont jeunes te regarde
aussi les chaînes youtube donc vous
regarder tout ça vous le dites ce que
vous en pensez ce que c'est un produit
qui pourrait vous intéresser vous
intéresser vos enfants mark et moi tout
ça en commentaire on en discute ensemble
je vous invite à mai s'est réjoui pousse
à vous abonner et puis on reste en
contact et puis on saura très bientôt
pour l'évolution et puis tout ça très
près la fille vanessa lutins